[Music]
so we just got back from playing three
hours of Assassin's Creed unity what did
you think of it I've only played a
couple of Assassin's games in the past I
played all of them but I felt like you
know I felt like this was a chance for
Ubisoft to do something really different
with the formula and yet it felt like
they didn't really you know they didn't
bring a lot of the lessons that they
could have learnt and brought forward
from previous Assassin's really what
kind of lessons we know things like the
parkour style and like the controls
still felt like you know I know
protagonist was a bit stickier that he
should have been in like a bit awkward
to control and I found like I thought
that previous Assassin's game might have
actually we'll see that's one of the
things like you now have a parkour
trigger that you hold down with right
trigger and then you have a stealth
trigger that you hold down with left
trigger so you can actually stick to
cover while you're in stealth mode
which is why it probably feels a bit
sticky but at the same time you also
have huh crawl up and parkour down while
you're holding the parkour trigger so
you don't just have that ability to kind
of hold forward hold parkour and have
him go exactly where he wants I know we
sort of found that when we were trying
to parkour across the rooftops more than
usual he was just sort of like not going
where we wanted and so jumping off in
sort of a random direction I think part
of why that parkouring feels slightly
more fiddly is because the architecture
has sort of a lot more detail per square
inch kind of thing so it's sort of like
there's more there are more elements to
each individual buildings and it's
harder to tell what is actually Klima
balandin tail the scenery what we've
done true to the error was breaking down
into districts so that's the first thing
each district kind of has its own flavor
and feel and that's very much where like
you mentioned architecture atmospherics
crowd composition all of that comes
together to add the feel global
illumination was a big addition it
really added to the warmth and the feel
of the bigger more grandiose areas but
we also have like I said the small in
the atmospheric sword there was a lot of
signal
you know feel in the rougher darker
areas and that very much adds into it so
it's a lot of it's the ability to break
the city into districts and then use
those components you know to come
together to add the feel that's not just
you can't really pinpoint one of the
other so one of the cool things they are
actually doing is they're implementing
what they call a black box design two
missions where it's less scripted than
previous Assassin's Creed games but you
still have things that would have been
scripted they're all now optional
objectives that just give you sort of
bonus rewards if you complete the
mission while doing them and we talk to
the dev about this and he was saying the
black box design extends to both the
single-player and co-op as well everyone
was always saying hey one can I play to
your friends and it's not so much it's
just having two assassins in Paris said
you know two Assassin's go killeth got
cool well how can we work together as a
team what are the kinds of skills and
tools that promote cooperative play and
so is being able to have those tools
those skills and those gameplay
opportunities it is very much added by
the addition of the black bones you know
having two people in a linear gameplay
situation you know is kind of
constricting and that you know the
benefit to that wasn't necessarily there
so it's really making sure that we were
supporting it so it wasn't just a
component of the game that it was
something that people were meant to play
and that they go joy of the shared
experience can take part in the
single-player campaign but we do take
the key components the single-player
campaign which is the black box which is
providing a goal and how you achieve
that is up to you and we've made
missions specifically like that tailored
to the online you are always Arno so
were your friends how we had a lot of
online is of when you load in you see
your friends with a different face and
they see you with a different face so
you are always our know and your friends
join us other assassins there's
definitely a very high density of
activities when you actually go through
each of different districts and yeah
that's sort of bringing back a bit of
that element of Assassin's Creed 2 and
sort of refurbishing the city and
finding ways to make that play into the
actual revolution itself from the part
you planner
[Music]